Chris Kyle is the U.S Navy SEAL Sniper
currently on a very important mission in
a third world country he is on the
rooftop of a building studying the path
of a U.S Convoy that might be in danger
everything seems smooth until a Muslim
woman carrying something underneath her
burka appears in Chris's view she hands
a grenade to a kid which he takes
towards the Convoy presumably to attack
it Chris gets the green light to shoot
the kid but his values put him in a
dilemma seconds later a loud gunshot is
heard and the scene cuts to Chris's
childhood he is in the woods hunting
with his father ever since he was little
he had a good aim which makes his father
think he will be a fine Hunter one day
Chris's father lives by the principle
that there are three types of people in
the world the Sheep the wolf and the
Sheepdog the Sheep are the weak ones who
cannot protect themselves The Wolves
prey on the weak and the sheep dogs are
the ones who protect their flock the man
wants his son to be a sheepdog and
protect his p people from the Wolves
many years later Chris turns into a
young man but doesn't forget his
father's words he is now a Rodeo Cowboy
living with his loving girlfriend Sarah
one night after a race he returns home
to Sarah and a man putting their clothes
on he beats the man up and kicks Sarah
out of the house before leaving she
calls him a failed farmer who claims to
be a so-called Cowboy Chris acts cool
but deep down he knows she is right he
hasn't been the Sheepdog that his father
wanted him to be after drinking all
night with his brother Chris comes
across news about explosions happening
in various U.S embassies in different
parts of the world the hundreds of
injured and dead Americans makes his
blood boil and gives him a purpose in
life the very next day he goes to Armed
Force career assistance wanting to join
the service the counselor admires his
determination and suggests he joined the
seals but not before stressing that most
people looking to enter the seals quit
in the first half Chris keeps that in
mind and joins the training apart from
everything else he is exceptionally good
at target shooting and has the potential
to become a skilled sniper fast forward
after a month's long extreme training he
finally passes the test and becomes a
member of the seals one night Chris is
enjoying a night out at a bar when he
meets a beautiful woman named Taya they
instantly connect and end the night
together in bed as time goes by they
fall in love with each other and get
married on the wedding day Chris and his
fellow seals are informed that they're
about to be deployed in Iraq they
celebrate the Milestone and are excited
about their first posting Taya however
is worried for her husband until he
assures her he will return after six
months the troop is assigned to the city
of faluya in Iraq and is stationed to
protect the first Marines who are going
door to door in an evacuated City to
look for terrorists the scene changes to
the beginning of the film when Chris is
ready to shoot the kid as the boy
Sprints towards the Convoy Chris fires
and brings him down the woman who gave
the boy the grenade rushes to him and
tries to continue the task but Chris
shoots her right through her chest and
the grenade explodes far from the Convoy
everyone Praises him for protecting the
Marines inside the Convoy who would be
dead by now if it weren't for him
however all Chris can think of is the
dead boy he never thought his first kill
would be a little kid who probably
didn't know what he was doing as days
pass Chris continues protecting the
troops from his position he's the best
sniper on his team so determined that he
urinates himself during the OverWatch to
avoid leaving his post who says peeing
your pants isn't cool after a particular
day at work he gets a total of six kills
which is more than the combined total of
all his teammates they start calling him
the legend but in his heart Chris
questions if he is the opposite then one
day he gets a call from Taya who
surprises him by revealing she is
pregnant they start talking on the phone
frequently taking care of each other
even though they aren't together in the
following scene the sniper team is in a
meeting where they are informed about an
Al-Qaeda leader named zarkawi their
primary target is the leader and his
lieutenants so if they find anything
suspicious related to his troop they
must act accordingly the team continues
the door-to-door search the next day
while Chris protects them from afar
everything goes smoothly until a soldier
is injured Chris takes it upon himself
to join the search team while his fellow
snipers watch over them during the
search they find an Arabic Sheik with
his family living in one of the houses
that were supposed to be empty the Sheik
claims that they don't have anywhere
else to go he wants the Americans to go
away because if the butcher catches them
talking with the U.S soldiers he will
kill the entire family the butcher turns
out to be one of zarkawi's subordinates
who could be useful to find the main man
the sheiku provided the information is
Promised a lot of money and a safe life
somewhere else the next day a military
vehicle moves out to meet the Sheik
again on their way Taya calls Chris and
informs him that they are about to have
a boy as his fellow seals congratulate
him the driver is shot and killed this
is when we are introduced to a terrorist
sniper Mustafa he is an Olympic gold
medalist known for making almost
impossible shots and is also the one who
has attacked them the absence of a
driver causes the vehicle to crash Taya
who is still on the phone panics and
asks Chris if he is okay but only hears
gunshots in reply Chris somehow manages
to find a hiding spot and spies on the
rivals the butcher holds the Sheik and
his family hostage before brutally
killing his son using a drill the Sheik
runs to the kid's rescue but is also
shot and killed Chris doesn't get a
chance to attack the enemies because
Mustafa is constantly firing at him
having found out where he is hiding in
the end both the Butcher and Mustafa
leave unharmed a few days later Chris
and his team returned home Taya is
beyond glad to see her husband well and
Alive however after living with him for
a few days she realizes that he is not
the the same person he was before being
deployed he is turned into a moody man
who complains about everything and has
forgotten how to enjoy life it is clear
that the things he saw and the things he
had to do have gotten into his head and
changed him as a person in the following
scene the couple is returning from a
trip to the hospital when Taya goes into
labor Chris turns the car back around
and a few hours later my beautiful baby
boy is born at home Taya encourages
Chris to talk about his feelings and
experiences she thinks letting it all
out will help him but he claims that he
doesn't want to get into her head and
dismisses the conversation he doesn't
want her to know that his problem is
that their baby is clearly fake soon
after he is informed that their team
will be heading to Iraq again Taya
doesn't want him to go but knows that he
is true to his job upon Landing in Iraq
they are told that their mission is to
hunt down the Butcher and Chris is
leading the team this time it turns out
that a bounty has been placed on Chris's
head by Al-Qaeda since he has killed
many of the their people during the
first Patrol of butcher's supposed
residents they come across a family the
head of the family claims that they know
nothing about the terrorists the team
believes him until Chris notices the
mark on his elbow that looks like he was
hurt in a war when no one is looking
Chris goes to search around his room and
finds heavy arms and ammunition inside a
hidden compartment in the floor the man
is instantly caught and interrogated to
save his life he promises to help the
soldiers get into the building where the
butcher is in the next scene the troops
cautiously surround the building the man
knocks on the door and is welcomed by
his fellow terrorist he is killed in an
instant followed by the man when he
tries picking up a gun the team then
enters the house and finds corpses cut
into pieces which is clearly the
butcher's work soon they are spotted and
the terrorists fire back the butcher
flees through a tunnel using the
shootout as a distraction when Chris
returns to the U.S again he struggles to
adjust to his normal life he is startled
by loud noises which remind him of the
war while he suffers in silence Taya
gives birth to their second child this
time a daughter Chris goes to see her in
the postnatal ward and Witnesses the
nurse tending to another child while his
daughter is crying he loses his mind
over the small incident and yells at the
nurses his strange Behavior doesn't go
unnoticed by Taya she frequently tells
him that he is never really present in
the moment and is always thinking of
something she wants him to talk to her
and tell her how he is feeling but he is
not ready to open up yet plus he's still
just mad about all these fake babies in
the following scene Chris's team is back
in Iraq chasing down the butcher's van
when the enemies start to fire they
respond and run to the nearest building
to retaliate with a better view suddenly
someone shoots down Chris's companion
Biggles Biggles
the group covers Chris while he brings
the injured Soldier to the vehicle and
rushes him to the base after making sure
that he gets proper Medical Care the
soldiers set off to look for the
terrorists again this time in Fury they
turn into killing machines taking out
every enemy they encounter at one point
they stop at a suspicious house to look
for more enemies but are ambushed by the
terrorists outside a soldier named Mark
dies in The ensuing shootout sometime
later the team returns home with Mark's
Body and attends his funeral Chris
reveals that he read a letter Mark wrote
before his death he claims that the
letter killed him because the guy had
given up on life even before he was
killed because of the letter Chris has
decided to go back for Revenge since he
cannot let his friends sacrifice go to
waste Taya tries to convince him
otherwise begging him to stay for his
kids she even tells him that he might
return to an empty home but Chris
doesn't listen when in Iraq he finds out
that Biggles died during surgery in a
usual Mission Chris sees a man with a
rocket-propelled grenade Aid getting
ready to attack the Convoy he shoots him
dead but notices that a kid is trying to
pick up the grenade to complete the task
Chris hopes that he doesn't have to kill
another boy and to his relief the kid
runs away when he cannot carry the heavy
propeller in the base he and his team
are told that the administration is
trying to build a wall around the city
however a terrorist has been firing at
them from over a thousand yards away
leading the team to believe it is
Mustafa the soldiers are asked to bring
down the sniper at any cost despite an
oncoming Sandstorm blocking their way
the team goes to protect the troops
building the wall they take their
positions aiming in the direction where
they think Mustafa is but he surprises
them by firing from the opposite
direction and killing a U.S soldier
Chris quickly tells his people to change
their positions and align themselves
according to his orders as he had
predicted he sees movement about 2100
yards away even though the others claim
that it is impossible to get a shot from
that far Chris confirms the target to be
he whispers for Biggles
under his breath before pulling the
trigger and finally killing the enemy
sniper however this also causes the
other terrorists to hear The Gunshot and
swarm the roof a shootout ensues which
causes serious damage to both parties
the troop is about to run out of ammo
when a sandstorm hits them Chris
believes that he is about to die and
calls Taya telling her that he is ready
to return home forever but right after
the call they decide to use the storm to
camouflage and run away Chris is shot
during the chaos but to his fortune the
soldiers see him running towards them
and pull him up he survives so he
probably doesn't want to go home anymore
the scene cuts to a few months later
Chris is drinking in a bar when he gets
a call from his wife he still suffers
from PTSD from the war and any loud
noises scare him Taya encourages him to
go to a psychiatrist which helps him a
lot he also joins a support group of War
veterans and talking to them makes him
feel seen with time he gets over the
trauma and starts to live life freely
even though he cannot turned back to his
young and carefree self after everything
he has seen Chris reconnects with his
family and moves to a new house with
them he also takes his son to hunt as he
did with his father become a sheepdog
like me son kill a thousand people on
February 2nd 2013 a young and troubled
ex-marine comes to meet him Chris tells
his wife he will be back by evening but
never returns it is later revealed that
the ex-marine who Chris was trying to
help killed him in the last scene we are
shown the picture of real-life Chris
Kyle his funeral and Taya delivering a
speech in his memory subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching